égaré elle pose à peine ses affaires
qu'il se met au travail cela fait trois
jours qu'il a pris ses fonctions de
directeur du chum
pour l'instant son bureau est encore
bien vengé pas couvert du dossier il a
commencé à visiter les différents
services sa priorité retrouver un
travail collectif
la première urgence point c'est que on
ré arrive à avoir confiance les uns dans
les autres que les gens réapprennent à
avoir confiance dans la direction
il ya des gros problèmes au niveau la
direction qu'on arrive à dialoguer et
notamment au niveau instance d'une autre
manière c'est le dialogue qui
actuellement trop violent mais je pense
que il ya les basses pour qu'on y arrive
une valeur à laquelle je suis vraiment
attaché c'est le respect et pour moi sur
certaines formes de dialogue qui a eu
avec plus de respect le respect les
soignants entre soignant direction
vis-à-vis des soignants et soignants
vis-à-vis de la direction
moi j'entends être exemplaire et il
montrer à quel point je suis attaché à
ce respect respecter les gens et je
pense que je souhaite que très
rapidement ce respect soit réciproque
la situation financière du chum est
difficile 800 millions de déficit cumulé
une dette d'environ 250 millions et une
absence de trésorerie qui empêche tout
investissement
un tableau noir qui ne semble pas
effrayer benjamin garrel qui se dit prêt
à prendre son bâton de pèlerin pour
aller chercher du sou dans les
ministères on a une difficulté sur la
trésorerie
d'accord moi ce que je vais finir de
regarder c est ce qu'on est capable de
régler seule ses difficultés ou pas ça
j'ai bien peur que ce sera effectivement
trop long je pense que si on
l'expliquent et qu'on me démontre on a
besoin d'une aide pour accélérer les
choses
l'état il a toujours écouté ce qui se
passait au niveau de la martinique moi
j'avais une image vraiment
un très négative en arrivant et de ce
que je vois c'est que j'ai vu un énorme
potentiel
d'accord je dis pas ça va être facile ça
va être hyper difficile on part pour un
marathon donné dans une situation où
ultra compliqué d'accord elle redressée
c'est pas en moi que ça va se compter 1
c'est en année d'accord mais pour moi ce
chu il ne devrait pas être dans cette
situation là jusqu'il ya vu les
professionnels qu'il a il devrait pas
une dans cette situation donc pour moi
il peut tout à fait sortir de l'ornière
je pense qu'on peut en deux ans on peut
arriver à des résultats
on n'aura pas résolu tous les problèmes
mais on peut arriver à ton maire chose
apaiser la tension et et assurer une
qualité sur plus de 90% des prises en
charge
irréprochable au niveau ni martinique
polytechnicien de 38 ans benjamin garrel
a travaillé au sein de plusieurs
hôpitaux à paris grenoble nancy dans ses
bagages le nouveau directeur du suma
aussi ramené une secrétaire général et
au nouveau directeur adjoint